[Música]
acho que cada um de vocês aqui já deve
ter vivido algo incômodo o incômodo
simples às vezes na cadeira um sapato ou
incômodo mais complexo no trabalho em
casa
na realidade que o cerca
o que importa é que a gente precisa
fazer alguma coisa com esse incômodo
esse incômodo precisa servir de alavanca
para a gente então ir para a ação e
tentar transformar assim como de alguma
oportunidade
hoje nós temos em torno de 5% da
população brasileira mais ou menos 10
milhões de pessoas que são classificadas
como de altas habilidades ou
superdotação
de acordo com a organização mundial de
saúde
imagina comigo quanto desses 10 milhões
são jovens em idade escolar
agora imagina comigo de novo quantos
desses jovens em idade escolar de altas
habilidades ou superdotação são de baixa
renda
sim porque por serem de baixa renda no
nosso país tem uma diferença de acesso a
uma educação de qualidade de acesso a
políticas públicas específicas que
possam de fato estimular esses jovens
esses alunos e alunas em idade escolar
para que eles possam de alguma forma
concretizar o seu pleno potencial e isso
vai fazendo com que esses jovens fiquem
invisibilizados na nossa sociedade e
isso gera um grande incômodo no já era
pensar nisso agora
e quando a gente fala de desses jovens
invisibilizados imagina o prejuízo para
uma nação de não ter uma evolução como
poderia se tivesse de fato
conscientemente tendo uma política para
identificar e para potencializar todos
esses talentos
sendo né há 20 anos esse incômodo pegou
de jeito um grupo de empresários com
forte apelo para a filantropia e
acreditando piamente que a educação é o
caminho da transformação social
e aí eles criaram um smart que é um
instituto social que identifica esses
jovens talentos acadêmicos de altas
habilidades e trabalha para concretizar
o pleno potencial deles por meio da
educação transformando tanto as próprias
vidas quanto as vidas das suas famílias
lá em 1999 quando o smart começou era
uma dificuldade de identificar esses
talentos acadêmicos e hoje ainda é de
maneira geral a gente conta muito com as
famílias e com os professores
principalmente que com esse olhar
cuidadoso e identifica alguns pontos de
comportamento fora da curva de alguns
alunos da sua sala de aula ea gente
trabalha muito próximo desses
professores principalmente porque é
importante identificar jovens de altas
habilidades para poder então concretizar
o pleno potencial bom se a gente for
pensar que a gente está mudando a vida
de algumas pessoas por meio da educação
já basta né
mas nesses 20 anos a gente tem percebido
com o nosso trabalho no smart que mudar
a vida de famílias e desses jovens por
meio da educação é só a ponta de uma
revolução
eu vou contar pra vocês para que vocês
vejam um pouco melhor o que a gente faz
a história da letícia rodrigues que
começa lá em 2008 no jardim sydney um
bairro aqui de são paulo
a letícia era uma aluna de uma escola
municipal que se destacava muito nas
aulas
adorava fazer olimpíadas do conhecimento
foi medalhistas em algumas olimpíadas e
uma das coisas favoritas que ela fazia
com os professores principalmente de
português era fazer exercícios extras de
gramática e ficar discutindo com essa
professora
depois do horário de aula
professora bastante cuidadosa e atenta
indicou letícia para fazer o processo
seletivo do smart
letícia se inscreveu junto com mais 10
mil alunos nessa época e foi aprovada
junto com outros 250 e começou sua
jornada numa escola parceira nossa aqui
em são paulo
letícia foi incentivada desde que ela
entrou conosco no 8º ano emocionalmente
e academicamente até o 3º ano do médio
nessa trajetória além de todos esses
estímulos ela também teve muitas
oportunidades de pensar concretamente
com a mão na massa qual seria a sua área
da graduação o que letícia faria no
ensino superior e para nós foi uma grata
surpresa quando ela escolheu fazer
engenharia prestou vestibular e passou
em engenharia da computação na usp e aí
uma nova trajetória começa à medida que
ela ia avançando na graduação ela ia
junto com o nosso apoio se desenvolvendo
em termos de comunicação se
desenvolvendo em termos competências
para trabalhar em equipe e conseguindo
cada vez mais outros desafios e
superando esses desafios tanto que meio
da sua graduação ela passou no processo
seletivo e teve oportunidade de fazer um
ano da sua engenharia na escola o
domínio do santos e tina uma das mais
interessantes escola de engenharia da
europa chegando lá por conta do seu
destaque ela passou num novo processo
seletivo e pode ficar mais um ano na
frança então ela teve uma oportunidade
renovada este ano
letícia acabou de se formar em
engenharia da computação
a alegria dela ela vê seus irmãos
menores e primos super inspirados por
ela dizendo que querem estudar fora que
querem fazer a universidade que querem
sonhar grande e pensar sem limites sem
dúvida letícia é uma grande inspiração
pra eles mas a maior inspiração
o que ela conquistou foi ver a mãe
também prestando vestibular
hoje dona tânia mãe de letícia a
cursando pedagogia nossa recém-formada
letícia já está no mercado de trabalho
ela hoje é desenvolvedora numa empresa
de tecnologia e é uma entre os quase
três mil bolsistas que nós temos na
nossa rede atualmente
quando você leva representatividade para
uma região menos favorecida
você influencia toda uma comunidade a
letícia sabe que ela como modelo tem um
efeito multiplicador poderoso e ela
continua na nossa rede trabalhando pra
ir atrás de resolver outros incômodos
que nós temos em cômodos de termos ainda
tantos jovens que não tiveram a
oportunidade da letícia em cômodos de
temos tantas meninas como letícia com
poucas figuras inspiradoras na área da
tecnologia das engenharias das exatas e
junto com ela a gente continua o nosso
trabalho porque pra gente
o incômodo serve como alavanca para
renovar as nossas esperanças a cada dia
e é isso que a gente faz dentro do smart
e era isso que eu queria contar pra
vocês aqui
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]